tu connais le dicton n'attaque jamais
une banque en face d'un resto qui a les
meilleurs donneurs se rend compte et
c'est pas un dicton si c'en est un non
ce n'est pas un champion du 10 mai s'est
pas indique thomas transcender tout le
monde s'assoit par terre
combien tu dirais 40 millions mais j'ai
une mauvaise nouvelle pour toi c'est une
plaque dans ta main et stu officiers
michael steegmans sa vieille bobine
c'était aux stocks qu'est ce qui s'est
passé je savais qu'ils étaient des
forces spéciales
c'est mon coeur
ah ah
la semoy toi tu meurs la banque c'était
un piège
il faut qu'on trouve à qui appartenait
le fric ouais ça veut dire bosser
ensemble ça veut pas dire patience
non ça veut dire bosser dans le même
voisinage semble maintenant dans la même
zone géographique ensemble
vous avez arnaquer la cia il est où le
fric
il n'est pas dans ce coin là ça je vous
le garantis les 24 heures pour
m'apporter le fait c'est quoi ton plan
je suis parfaitement capable de pondre
un plan ou peut-être de manière c'était
son plan personnes qui attendaient taux
réduits voire quatre
qu'est ce que tu peux les sa confiance
fini de rigoler vous êtes convenablement
motivation n'est plus que vous le croyez
fait pleuvoir du fait partie de mon clan
ewing
tout va pour le maître qui se battait
côté